madame monsieur bonsoir aucune femme ne
peut y rester indifférente
aucun homme ne devrait l'être et dans
notre société c'est sans doute l'un des
problèmes précipitée par l'évolution des
moeurs qui divise le plus profondément
les français je veux parler de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
autrement dit de l'avortement au terme
d'une longue bataille menée par les
mouvements féministes et certains
mouvements médicaux l'avortement est
légal en france depuis 75 mais jusqu'ici
il n'était pas remboursée par la
sécurité sociale
le remboursement était une promesse de
la campagne présidentielle socialiste
pour toutes sortes de raisons notamment
financières le gouvernement ne semblait
pas pressé de l'appliquer sous la
pression des mouvements féministes et
d'une partie des députés socialistes
le premier ministre il ya quelques jours
en a précisé le principe selon un projet
de loi qui va être soumis au parlement
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
sera remboursé par la sécurité sociale
le ticket modérateur restant à la charge
de l'intéressé et l'état versant à la
sécurité sociale
les sommes nécessaires le projet a
aussitôt suscité des réactions diverses
totale opposition des groupes engagés
contre l'avortement satisfaction dans le
camp opposé mais cette issue action
nuancé nuance visible cet après midi
lors de la manifestation organisée à
paris par le planning familial
l'association choisir le moullac et les
groupes femme sylvie marion
elle l'avait bien dit les femmes elles
voulaient descendre dans la rue
encore une fois pour se réjouir de la
dernière mesure annoncée par le
gouvernement le remboursement de l'ibg
par la sécurité sociale avant la fin de
l'année mais aussi pour demeurer
vigilantes
nous sommes contentés les sommes
heureuses années fait que les luttes des
femmes est gagné et que nous ayons gagné
sur l'avortement c'est vrai sur le
remboursement des légers mais enfin nous
sans rupture historique parce que d'une
part que la reconnaissance du droit mais
en même temps mais en même temps on le
met à peu dans un ghetto parce que ce
remboursement qui est une mesure de
justice sociale
on me donne un peu l'étoile jaune de
l'acte médical
je crains de choses d'une barre
le remboursement de l'avortement est
soumis au vote des députés à chaque
année donc à aucune garantie dans
l'avenir d'autre part ça signifie d'un
point de vue moral et idéologique que le
gouvernement se refuse encore à
considérer l'avortement comme un acte
médical continue à le considérer comme
une démarche à part et or c'est
justement contre sa course et les restes
puisque pour nous ça doit pas être autre
chose qu'un acte médical choisi par les
femmes
l'enfant on a quand même gagné et si on
est dans la rue c'est un peu pour que ça
dure
oh
en vérité les craintes exprimées cet
après midi par les femmes entre
montparnasse et la concorde reflète leur
désir de voir le remboursement de l'ibg
se transformer en a fait de société sur
lequel on ne pourra jamais revenir